ils sont en plein dedans mais bon c'est
des garçons donc c'est pas pareil je
suis peut-être moins inquiète que si
j'avais eu des filles mais effectivement
tik tok je pense et c'est ce que je dis
à maison je pense que c'est assez un
réseau sur lesquels viennent chasser les
pédophiles mais j'en suis persuadé et
toutes ces jeunes filles là qu'on voit
enfin moi ça m'inquiète beaucoup en
fait non mais je trouve que toutes ces
jeunes filles qui sont là en croque top
passe à se remuer comme ça et c'est sur
que c'est pas une très bonne idée et
d'ailleurs quand même tik tok a légiféré
la chose c'est à dire entre eux je crois
que c'est entre 13 maintenant et 15 ans
les enfants qui sont sur tik tok sont
obligés de passer en privé en mode privé
mais problème c'est qu'en fait le but
c'est d'avoir le plus de followers donc
il exclut de rendre n'importe qui donc
je ne sais pas si c'est vraiment la
bonne la bonne solution et il paraît
aussi que sur tik tok j'ai vu ça en
renseignant on propose des vidéos
apparemment scatophile et zoophiles mais
je suis tombé je suis persuadé week end
ou pas j'ai découvert ça la salle tic
toc euse sur le plateau ces douze cars
est donc quand même touche car faut-il
interdire tik tok au aux moins de 16 ans
interdire j'irai pas jusque là parce que
de toute façon c'est pas possible faut
vivre avec son temps c'est la nouvelle
génération mais je pense qu'il faudrait
un peu plus de de sécurité au niveau des
parents parce que pour moi le portable
c'est pas une nourrice et je pense
qu'ils les parents de vigilance les
parents ouais ils ne tuent peut pas
accéder aux portables des enfants ait eu
à l'école pourquoi n'at-on pas tu
redonnes
c'était pareil aujourd'hui les enfants
ils sont alors à coeur comme tu peux pas
imaginer ils ont des codes des trucs et
cela et qu'on tourne tout moi je sais tu
vas tu mets un contrôle parental sur un
appareil il le déverrouillage sur un
autre mais oui enfin on trouve pas ces
vidéos si allal certains sur tic tac des
vidéos notamment de chirurgie raté je
sais qu'on a le
[Musique]
quand la mise quand la mise en scène de
soi va jusque là je pense que c'est
quand même un petit peu dangereux on a
aussi un dd challenge en tous genres sur
tik tok certains sont aussi extrêmement
dangereux et carrément interdit par la
plateforme celui-là il s'appelle le
vidéo milk krayt challenge il s'agit de
d'empiler des briques de lait d'essayer
de l'escaladé regardez
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
évidemment à ne surtout pas reproduire
chez vous
sur maxime tictoc ce genre de challenge
débile ou alors trouver sur twitter sur
facebook c'est qu'ils sont petits blocs
exactement on est d'accord général mais
c'est surtout sur lynch est désolé parce
que tu parlais des enfants des ados
comme ça c'est pas la faute aux tic top
si ton enfant witwer qui est devant la
caméra dans sa chambre c'est ton enfant
qu'il faut qu'il faut remettre en cause
ce n'est pas l'application
une surenchère aussi
c'est plutôt d'accord avec vous au foot
on sait rien du tout bon jour parce que
moi hors champ je trouve après ça que
j'ai pas free rock star et je suis pas
encore je peux encore père mais par
contre moi je trouve honnêtement que
c'est très très compliqué on voit même
le black out challenge et une petite
fillette de 10 ans aux états unis qui
est décédé voilà dix huit vallées
doucement pour avoir reproduit un siège
comme ça et moi je pense que dans une
société où l'apparence est vraiment en
premier plan il ya aussi cette hyper
sexualisation par des welters mais
également il ya aussi et il ya aussi les
femmes qui veulent ressembler à des
modes et le quai voix sur tic toc et à
me reposer le même schéma avec eux les
filtres avec la chirurgie et c est moi
je pense à mon sens que c'est une faute
représentation de la société et ça pour
moi savamment lordat des salaires parce
que vraiment cette info miroir et toutes
ces personnes ce qui se trouve non non
pas du tout les finir
il
est donc du coup non pour football pour
finir je pense voilà que à force de
vouloir être trop brillante hâtif je
pense qu'on va se perdre voilà
simplement boire la tasse
alors moi je pense que non faut pas
interdire ce qu'on sait que les jeunes
aient le goût de l'interdît leblanc
tripoli gène c'est plus fort que tout
donc les jeunes ils vont y aller encore
plus en fait faut que les parents et
enseignants etc plus débattre de sa sans
tabou avec les jeunes et si on rend sa
interdite on pourra pas en parler ils
vont faire cette manière clandestine etc
mais l'interdiction la réglementation
peut-être au laguna en plus de cela vous
montrer la dark side entre guillemets de
tik tok moi je suis gentil toc enfin je
sais que je suis plié de rire mais
presque tous les sens que je te vois des
trucs hilarant moi je sais qu'à l'époque
où j'étais au lycée il y avait de la
population de ce match en 2016-2017
voyage vous tapez mais des baigneurs
deux fois avec mes amis ça crée des
liens et c'est sûr mais la halle en
parler plutôt d'un jeune des dix des dix
quinze ans qui s'est pourtant quand il
ya moyen de s'assurer
qu'on s'adressait pas à charlotte est ce
qu'il faut interdire tik tok l'achat
mais on a été pas mal j'ai parlé enfin
je me revoyais j'étais au collège etc
avec deux matches cependant je me taper
des barres de fous des délires de fou et
je pense qu'il ya aussi moyen de se
taper des bailleurs de fonds et de créer
des liens grâce à twitter et autres
aides tik tok voulu faire de la
sensibilisation et les parents puissent
en parler sans tabou avec les jeunes ce
qui donc demandé à ce qu une balade en
roulotte et il ya deux solutions en fait
c'est sous les parents une éducation aux
médias et 2 que les autorités
contraignent ces plateformes bien ses
limites et d'arrêter la responsabilité à
des plateformes et c'est tout à fait
d'ailleurs on vous a préparé un petit
aperçu quand même de ce qu'on trouve de
mieux sur tik tok charlotte a raison
douchka aussi qu'il y ait qui tous les
jours jean-michel aussi même si vous
êtes un taux moins tic toc heures que
quand
on regarde tout de suite la vidéo la
plus vue de 2021 ça implique un mec
normal un drone et décadence
à
il
m
enfin
[Musique]
donc on est quand même dans une très
bonne ambiance très un mec qui dansent
un drone c'est ça aussi tik tok et c'est
la vidéo la plus vue de 2021 millions de
personnes qui ont vu sort
virale pour la bonne humeur pour
l'ambiance et pour la petite bande son
qui est la bouée plaisante championnat
mais je suis les déchets ce qui saute
dans les sapins et ses
gardes et justement on enchaîne avec la
vidéo la plus vue de toute l'histoire de
tik tok depuis la création ça implique
un peu harry potter la magie moi j'adore
[Musique]
je la regardais ce
qui est vraiment le magicien des effets
spéciaux mais derrière il ya énormément
de budget a bien sûr énormément
d'occasions mais pour
cette offre est récente et s'assurer que
sur twitter on trouve aussi des vidéos
qui sont très créatives des choses qu'on
n'a pas forcément l'habitude de voir sur
instagram sans fin sans stress est donc
sacrée bouteille et du coup c'est cool
que y ait une plate forme ludique sur
lesquelles on peut voir ça et on
enchaîne avec le tictoc heures le plus
célèbre il s'appelle cabine lane est
originaire du sénégal et la 130 millions
d'abonnés est toujours le même concept
de vidéo plutôt très drôle
[Applaudissements]
projet c'est quoi le projet le projet
c'est le décalage génial ironie c'est un
moment génial c'était mozart
c'est justement c'est l'absurdité
d'accord j'ai 60 ans j'ai tellement
d'intérêt à quêter nas
et on va regarder la plus grande chaîne
de l'histoire de tik tok alors les
chaînes c'est une personne qui fait une
vidéo puis une autre qui utilisent la
même vidéo etc etc etc sera jusqu'à ce
que ça devienne virale là tout est parti
d'un chat qui fait du bruit en buvant
son lait
[Musique]
elle
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
seulement ces seules six allemands
n'avaient pas toutes ces vidéos bizarre
et dangereuse à côté c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment tout ce qu'on aime et on
termine avec la vidéo la plus laïque et
de toute l'histoire de titeuf c'est que
de 50 millions de like dites nous si
vous comprenez pourquoi on regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas trop se battre eux sont des hui
on a dit ça pas beaucoup d'intérêt et
une fille qui
elle et elle est très connue elle fait
partie des personnalités les plus
suivies sur tik tok et elle reprend l'un
des des dix mines des sortes de vidéos
les plus partagées sur tik tok et le
leap seul à sa mort donne isation
labiale ont fait du playback en gros
avec des petites expressions de visage
un petit peu mignonne ça cartonne sur
titan qui sait que vous voulez que je
vous dise que j'ai rien parce que là on
est quand tu vois que certains se creuse
la tête pour faire des vidéos ici
percevez ce ticket et que là elle
cartonne avec la pitchouli qui est une
star
oui d'accord et pour finir parce qu'on a
tous été fasciné par l'univers de titeuf
parce que jean michel a découvert depuis
la première fois l'existence de ce
réseau social la diversité qu'on y
trouve on vous a préparé un florilège
des tripes toc les plus d'extraordinaire
on regarde
mais
une agglo
seck tepa mannequin l'histoire y avait
le jus qui sortait
[Musique]
sur les vidéos les plus extraordinaires
mais les vidéos marrantes certaines
étaient quand même très très drôle et
figurez-vous qu'en france le conti coq
le plus suivi c'est le compte du paris
saint germain c'est le contexte papa
évidemment non et les deux autres
comptes tik tok les plus suivies ces
décomptes de sportifs qui réalisent des
challenge assez impressionnant est ce
que vous êtes convaincus par le tictoc
c'est qu'aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui a un
vrai talent il peut plus passer inaperçu
cirque il aura trouvé un moyen tik tok
ou instagram autre chose nous montrer ce
qu'il sait faire et voilà que ce soit en
musique aux peintures en art n'importe
quoi il a des moyens d'expression qu'on
n'avait pas moi quand j'étais jeune
j'aurais pu percer vous même chose que
l'industrie musicale qui regarde le nom
beaucoup dicton bien des tendances et
qui repère les nouveaux talents et
social tout le monde s'il est absolument
tout le monde même les politiques même
la campagne présidentielle se joue sur
tik tok